[Music]
first of all congratulations this is a
record-breaking historic opening for a
movie you must be very excited did did
pretty good pretty good yeah now you
were been promoting this movie for a
long time you were actually promoting
the movie for a long time before you
even saw it which I think it's got to be
kind of weird right yeah yeah I mean at
that point when you're promoting
something that you haven't seen it's a
little nerve-racking because so much
expectation and you're talking about it
being a great film but you don't even
know if it's a great film at that point
you're out there saying you got a seat
it's the greatest thing ever yeah you
haven't seen it yet and then you had
that moment where you went into a movie
theater and you must be some part of
this a little scare but you go into
screening room they say now we're
finally gonna show it to you just told
half the globe it's really good I
require specifically requested to see it
on my arm the first time because I was I
was too nervous everyone was talking
about and hyping it up and when I did
see it I was I was very relieved yeah I
got to see it a couple days ago with my
staff and it's a really good movie it's
a great you guys did a great job and so
what would you have done if you had gone
into that private screening room and
they had shown it to you and it was just
a mess what would you do then there was
a few options one was just kill myself
it's always enough yeah like just kill
yourself it's worth it today the
interviews are more Frank than any
interviews I've ever had within you just
said well I could kill myself good night
everybody